I've been a fan of yours for a very long
time it is great to talk to you uh I
would imagine that no matter where you
go people want to come up to you and
talk to you because it's you what do you
find that people always want to ask you
about is there like one particular role
or does it depend where you are it's
it's funny first of all and this is
really interesting just about people in
general uh they usually don't ask a
question they'll tell you something and
and which is very funny right
um because I I can't imagine that I'm
any different but the first of all
people have been incredibly kind to me
over the years uh and really supportive
and and I've had you know my life has
gone up and down my career has gone up
and down uh but people have been really
cool with me and I'm grateful for that
and I would have to say probably more
than not
someone will tell me and it doesn't
matter their age
but they'll tell me that they had a
relationship with lost boys that was
really special and so if it's an older
person they'll tell me that they saw it
when they when you know I was they were
mine when I was my age when we made it
like they saw it when for the first time
when they were like 18 19 years old and
for the younger people they'll tell me
that their dad or their granddad showed
it to them and uh
and it's very sweet that that kind of
film for whatever reason I I couldn't
explain it to you but the fact that
that people are handing it down from
generation to generation speaks volumes
to me uh and I was just so proud to be a
part of it for that reason alone
um that it meant that to those people
jumping into why I get to talk to you um
I'm imagining that you get offered
scripts what was it about this material
that said oh I need to do this well
first of all I'm a huge fan of John
England and and it's just not as writers
and directors separately and then
ultimately together
um
they said well we've got we've got this
idea and we're it was a really loose
kind of conversation
um you know and we're going to kind of
hearken back to these Thrillers from the
70s like three days of the Condor and
you know the Parallax View and and
Marathon Man and now these are all the
films that I grew up on and that that I
have such fond memories of and that that
when I started my career I really wanted
to get to do those films those kinds of
movies that I watched
um and then they got to describing the
character and the thing about the
character that caught me out of the gate
that I found really interesting and
thought okay I know where to start
was that this guy was you know is a
predator on some level he was he was the
Hunter he was the one who was setting up
other companies uh and and using
misinformation to kind of make them
believe something else was happening and
he took that and and and turned it into
a profit for the company that had hired
him
and then within minutes you know just
like he was working a scam on someone
else someone got him and he goes
literally uh in the first episode 180
degrees and goes from you know Hunter to
hunted and goes from strong to
vulnerable
and anytime you get to watch a character
kind of make that kind of an about face
turn
and you see them emotionally
invulnerable and and weak
there's an identifiable quality to that
that I just think is interesting to
watch and I think very identifiable I I
I can't tell you that I've gotten
through a single day in my life that I
haven't done that whole 180 degree turn
you know literally from my I'll get out
of my car and I feel really confident
going into the grocery market and then
something happens in aisle six and I'm
like well I don't feel as confident
anymore and and of course it's on a much
smaller level but I think it's happening
to us all the time and I think when you
when they wrote something then laid it
out kind of that precisely I was like
yeah I know I know how to start here and
get to this other part and then I think
that we'll have a character that people
are gonna identify with and then
ultimately root for
um because you know he doesn't start off
clean he's he's doing some bad stuff too
and and yet
once it turned on him uh
I really felt for him and then I also
felt that just over the course of the
over the course of the Season that he
was learning stuff about himself too
that that would become very relatable as
well one of the things I was wondering
as I was watching the show or I actually
want to ask you this
um it's about you know um uh
I feel like stuff being depicted on the
show could absolutely be happening in
real life so do you think what you're
showing on the show is being done by
corporations and people uh the way it's
being depicted on the show I I would
think probably on a much more
sophisticated level yes yeah I mean I I
think you know we run we run a scam on a
guy that's pretty pedantic and and
actually almost comical uh because of
what we do and I don't want to ruin what
the scam is but I think on a much more
sophisticated level yes I think I think
companies are doing it to other
companies I think countries are doing it
to other countries uh and and you know
look it took us decades to to adapt to
the Industrial Revolution and I think we
still are and it's going to take us
decades to adapt
to the ramifications and realities of
the technological Revolution that we're
still in the middle of and so you know I
guarantee you when I see on CNN
you know this this profile about
AI voice uh matching uh and that that
with a computer and a few words of
Leonardo DiCaprio's voice I I can I can
make a whole script and it'll sound like
him
well if I'm seeing that on CNN I promise
you I'm the last guy to know and that
technology has been around for a while
and it's been used and I think sometimes
fun for a joke and I think probably
sometimes not so fun yeah I just think
about what it's going to be in five and
ten years uh which is really scary
um well yeah and it's and and it is
scary you know and uh you know but I I
do have faith I I actually might be one
of the last people that has faith in
people and and I think that you know uh
we'll bump into some things and and
we'll go okay that's we're going to have
to work on that and we're gonna have to
and I think we as a society have to just
kind of try our hardest to do the better
and the good thing uh it doesn't mean
that that's gonna
be easy and smooth sailing and then it's
not going to require a fight
um but yeah it's it's it's a very tricky
world to navigate right now uh and I
think our show for better and For Worse
kind of represents that I'm just one of
the things I've seen four of the Eight
Episodes and one of the things that uh
as I was watching it and uh and the
audience will they're always on their
toes because they're not sure who is on
what side it keeps there's you know
you're you're and what was it like for
you did John did you guys did they tell
you the whole Arc of everything before
you started filming or how much were you
reading at script by Script and actually
wondering I don't know if this character
is going to be on my side or not
um I got four up front
um we talked in loose terms about the
overall Arc because I think and this is
something that I really did experience
on 24. uh Howard Gordon on 24 would we
we would we would get together go out
for a couple beers and and he'd lay out
kind of his idea for the whole season
and we talk and he'd had a couple things
and what if we tried this and but
we'd walk away from that dinner thing we
had the beginning the middle and the end
right and I can almost say to a t every
year that end note it was about episode
14. and and it would change right and it
would change based on what we were
actually doing so so it was fluid it was
and exciting because you know certain
scenes you were doing you're going
that's good we gotta we gotta lean into
that we got to write more towards you
know this conflict or that situation and
and and so I wanted that same freedom
for John and Glenn to have on this and
and they took it and so so the last
couple episodes were like
they
yeah there was stuff that I wasn't
expecting and I had to adapt to and um
and that's what makes it exciting and
that note I need to wrap I'm just gonna
say congrats I'm looking forward to
seeing five through eight